how'd you know you're doing grace we'll
find out yay-yay that your impression of
me yes there you guys I'm here with Keon
Lally hello Tien came over and we
recorded an episode of the podcast so
make sure you go over to SoundCloud or
iTunes to listen to that podcast and
while he was here I thought we'd play a
challenge video game YouTube thing if
you couldn't tell already we are playing
the soda pong challenge and you've done
this before I've done one version of it
okay I lost so well you know there we go
again here we go again now the game
works like beer pong where you have a
triangle shape of cups cups with alcohol
yes but for this challenge we have
terrible flavored soda how many good
ones are there how many good ones either
yeah yeah and it's also personal
preference but we've heard that there's
flavours potentially like ranch or bacon
or celery sodas so we are each going to
take turns throwing a ball at this
triangle formation if one of us gets it
in the other person has to drink from
that cup and try and guess what the
flavor of soda is you get a point for
getting the ball in the cup you get a
point if you guess the flavor correctly
the person with the least amount of
points at the end of this game has to
drink a special cocktail prepared by the
other player you worded that beautifully
I just say in words didn't even make any
sense let's play shall we who goes first
I feel like you go first I know I'm
gonna be a gracious host and let you go
crazy [ __ ] I'm gonna be gracious host
and let you have the first chance so we
need the ping pong ball please
ready someone fun a service you can do
it this you get the opportunity to get
in you have the easiest formation right
now to get it in there yeah but I don't
know like the velocity and speed of like
I should throw it okay I'm just gonna go
for it so much science go for it I love
my life man I have a ball my heart is
like okay this could be a long video yep
there goes Thank You Laura
thank the Lord oh just get in the way
I'm getting the weight of it down yeah
okay yes oh this is gonna be the longest
video of all time you make one oh okay
here you go
it's what what describe what you see I
thought it was coke but it doesn't look
like coke try it we'll see what it is
taste like what okay what what's your
guess I'll taste it as a sign of
camaraderie
oh that's coffee wow that that hits you
like that's coffee for sure espresso
coffee bean what is it it's bacon it's
bacon Bay so right now I have one point
and you have zero points you know cuz
this is a game and we're keeping points
oh oh sorry for sure she got robbed
don't make it thank you you're welcome
I just want you to drink one right make
it watch you do it oh oh yeah why this
is called let's give the audience
anxiety is this challenge my heart is
still just like bah bah bah bah bah bah
why
looks like piss yes that's what it looks
like it looks like a dehydrated human
being relieve themselves it doesn't have
a smell I'm okay honestly terrified
right now
it doesn't have a smell grace grace that
D what is it I get to see it oh my god
it's like a sour ass it's not bad
cooling Theory like the coffin takes
like bitter scotch
what is widenar scotch oh just the sheer
version of butterscotch very very good
the dollar store version of butterscotch
is bitter scotch okay that's also gonna
be my stripper name
bitter Scott so I have two points and
you have zero point thank you for coming
up you're welcome guys it's really
important for the audience to stay a
part of this go for it I'm gonna make
one oh yeah smells a lot oh it smells
well from here and it's the color it's
like a tan or beige color so I don't
know what it is um Oh what it's on your
head
it's for sure all in your head I'm gonna
say uh expired cream soda apple pie
what up much yeah this is like literally
a cat came to life I was like imagining
what these flavors are a pie okay dude
one if you do two one oh my god
very beer-pong you can get like a rear a
Krait yes we get a rear AK you know what
yes you've been through a lot Jerry Rice
you sound so professional
I've watched a couple games I hate this
part of beer pong the rear AK okay
okay mm-hmm yeah I'm coming back
this is coke great I love ya I have two
points all right three
yes a close game if you make this I'm
basically up we'll see I still have a
charm czar stronger than my taste buds
ma ah she's really working up a thirst
oh oh oh my good lord
brick brick brick brick what beef
oh yeah I feel like just two shacks on
the couch taking free throws right now
good it looks so much further away this
is gonna be a fun montage stressful for
everyone involved don't invite me to
your frat parties oh I was so close you
thought about it I instantly thought
about going all right now that may be
touching again we're gonna be here till
tomorrow I know this is the part that we
didn't get it didn't three-two-three
eight night to guess this flavor please
get this oh it's like a milky orange
color okay
nothing you might take a sip this one
I'm gonna say based on the color like
like like carrots okay you're way off
what is it what's the opposite of like a
carrot the opposite of a carrot human
shape it's buttery strawberry what am i
fear no don't hold onto it Kat came to
life decided these are all the flavors
three two three oh this makes me anxious
I know you're gonna make this first try
already not a cool moment okay go ahead
all of it's awful they linger all the
flavors linger for literally half the
distance to the god yeah oh my heart is
dropped to my stomach
yeah my stomach is feeling so many
thanks oh oh please don't
okay watch his face is how you do that
was great how did I do that hungry this
is also Orange but less milky than the
last one I'm gonna say buttery carrots
know it okay it's sweet corn you get to
make a cocktail for me to talk about to
try so you get to mix whatever you want
and here's a new cup for you I'm going
all except coke I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do a little bit of each so you have to
take the whole swig I'm a great host I
just want everyone to know that right
now so when you pick your nominations
for the Streamy Awards every year thing
wasn't for the netted a wedding here
you're putting a Bloody Mary what are
you calling this cocktail bloody corn ah
I came back Oh much corn it tastes like
you ever wonder what like a candle from
Bath & Body Works tastes like [ __ ] yeah
it's basically I can thank you so much
for being here
I mean I say that I don't know if I
really feel that well you make sure that
you listen to the podcast not too deep
the episode with kyun over on iTunes or
SoundCloud and go check out Qian's
channel it's super key in 13 yes and
kyun and JC you I didn't have to say
anything and go check out the chosen
movie I love it yeah so many things to
check out I'm gonna check out the inside
of my toilet with my mouth in a little
bit high I don't know who anyone else
liked it you know me okay please sit up
horn throw my new pants ran back to my
room turn on my TV and i sat there
doesn't it oh my god I didn't and I was
so young I didn't know what happened I
like you don't even know what the words
sharp meant okay I think did I fart what
I do